>> Tucker: EXECUTIVES AT THE
OPIOID MANUFACTURER PURDUE
PHARMA CLAIM FOR YEARS THEY
WEREN'T AWARE THAT FLAG SHIP
DRUG THE ONE FROM WHICH THEY
MADE MOST OF THEIR PROFITS
OXYCONTIN WIDELY ABUSED BY
USERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
NOW, AFTER MAKING BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS AFTER THE WORST
DRUG CRISIS IN THE HISTORY
OF THIS COUNTRY ONES OF
WHICH TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE HAVE DIED.
"NEW YORK TIMES" HAS UP
COVERED DOCUMENTS PURDUE
PHARMA EXECUTIVES WERE AWARE
OF ABUSE EVEN AS THEY
AGGRESSIVELY MARKETED THE
DRUG TO NEW USERS SOME OF
WHOM DIED.
BARRY MYERS.
EMPIRE OF DECEIT.
OPIOID EPIDEMIC JOINS US
NOW.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: THIS STORY HAS
NOT RECEIVED ENOUGH
ATTENTION.
TELL US WHAT PURDUE PHARMA
KNEW.
>> REMARKABLY, WHAT THEY
KNEW WAS THAT THE DRUG WAS
BEING ABUSED.
THEY HAD GOTTEN SPECIAL
PERMISSION FROM THE FDA TO
PROMOTE THIS DRUG LESS PRONE
TO ABUSE.
THEY TOOK THIS CLAIM THEY
RAN WITH IT.
THEY MADE CLAIMS THAT WERE
NOT TRUE.
DURING THAT WHOLE TIME, THEY
WERE AWARE THAT PEOPLE WERE
ABUSING THE DRUG.
THEY HAD REPORTS FROM THEIR
DOCTORS.
THEY HAD REPORTS FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS.
AND THEY SAT ON THESE
REPORTS.
THEY MADE MADE NO MENTION OF
THEM TO REGULATORS, TO
AUTHORITIES, TO LAWMAKERS.
AND THEY JUST KEPT SELLING
AND SELLING AND SELLING.
>> Tucker: SO, LOOKING BACK,
I MEAN, THIS DRUG WAS
SHIPPED TO SOME COUNTIES
FAMOUSLY IN KENTUCKY AND
WEST VIRGINIA IN QUANTITIES
THAT WEREN'T JUSTIFIABLE
UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCES,
LEGITIMATE CIRCUMSTANCES YOU
CAN IMAGINE.
IT MUST HAVE BEEN OBVIOUS
WHAT WAS GOING ON.
THEY MUST HAVE KNOWN.
WHY HAS NO ONE BEEN CHARGED
FROM THIS COMPANY?
>> WELL, IN FACT, THE
PROSECUTORS THAT
INVESTIGATED THIS COMPANY
WANT YOU HAD TO CHARGE THEM.
THEY WANTED TO BRING VERY
SERIOUS CHARGES AGAINST THE
EXECUTIVES.
OUR REPORT AND THE MATERIAL
THAT IS IN PAIN KILLER IS
DRAWN FROM A JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT REPORT IN WHICH
PROSECUTORS RECOMMENDED
CHARGING THREE TOP
EXECUTIVES OF PURDUE PHARMA
WITH SERIOUS FELONIES THAT
WOULD HAVE SENT THEM TO
PRISON.
BUT THEY GOT STOPPED BY TOP
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS
WHO BLOCKED THESE
INDICTMENTS.
>> Tucker: WHO ARE THE
OFFICIALS WHO BLOCKED THOSE
INDICTMENTS?
>> THEY WERE THE TOP PEOPLE
IN THE BUSH ADMINISTRATION
WHO ARE RUNNING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AT THAT TIME.
>> Tucker: IT'S ABSOLUTELY
UNBELIEVABLE.
>> IT IS UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK WE
PASSED A POINT WHERE IT
WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE TO
CHARGE THE PEOPLE PARTLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DEATHS
OF TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS FOR CRIMES?
>> YOU KNOW, THEY -- THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
PROBABLY RUN ON THESE
CRIMES.
IT'S PROBABLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
BRING CRIMINAL CHARGES.
THERE ARE A LOT OF CITIES
AND STATES THAT ARE BRINGING
CIVIL CHARGES, CIVIL
LAWSUITS AGAINST PURDUE
PHARMA.
I MEAN, I THINK THE
IMPORTANT THING IS THIS:  WE
ARE NOW IN THE MIDST.
AND YOU HAVE REPORTED ON IT
OF A GREAT PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS.
THE ONLY WAY TO GET OUT OF
IT IS TO UNDERSTAND HOW IT
STARTED.
HOW DOES A STORY THAT PAIN
KILLER TELLS.
AND WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND
THAT STORY.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHO NEEDS TO
BE HELD TO ACCOUNT.
WE CAN'T TREAT CORPORATE
EXECUTIVES WITH KID GLOVES
WHEN THESE COMPANIES ARE
FLOODING OUR COUNTRY WITH
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
PAIN PILLS.
>> Tucker: LIFE EXPECTANCY
FOR MIDDLE CLASS AMERICANS